nous avons rendez-vous chez vinerberger
le leader de la terre cuite ici dans
leur usine près de Strasbourg sortent
chaque année 150 000 tonnes de briques
mais depuis quelques mois bien que le
carnet de commandes soit rempli
l'entreprise n'est pas sereine
on vient récupérer cet argile et ensuite
on va broyer cette matière première la
façonner la sécher la cuire pour avoir
une brique finie avant que ça
particulière
autant d'étapes qui pèse chaque jour un
peu plus sur l'entreprise alors jusque
là sur les deux premières plusieurs
étapes voyage transport plus façonnage
on a utilisé que de l'électricité
c'est l'équivalent de la consommation
électrique de 850 petits logements
pas mal d'électricité mais l'électricité
chez nous le représente que 10 à 15 % de
notre mix énergétique la grosse part
c'est le gaz naturel qui est utilisé
et pour cause l'entreprise dispose d'un
four de 180 mètres de long atteignant
les 900 degrés
on va sortir plus de 25 tonnes de
produits par heure la montée en
température d'un four froid peut prendre
plusieurs jours jusqu'à 5 jours chez
nous donc il faut bien comprendre que
c'est pas un système on off on va pas
couper le four pour leur démarrer une
heure après l'idée c'est quand il est
lancé chez nous nos période d'activité
sont de plus de 18 mois une entreprise
énergievort qui n'a à ce jour aucune
autre solution pour produire de la
brique en terre cuite on peut observer
une augmentation du gaz de X 10
quasiment depuis quelques mois et
quasiment de de x 20 sur l'électricité
donc si on prend un exemple concret nos
produits entre 2000 2020 et aujourd'hui
les produits ont été augmentés de 25%,
une augmentation du prix de vente et une
marge rabotée alors pour sauver
l'entreprise Frédéric doit prendre des
mesures d'urgence on est vraiment dans
l'obligation d'aller chercher chaque
perte d'énergie d'entreprise à travers
une équipe dédiée dans le Lean
management pour aller chercher vraiment
chaque gâchis d'énergie et donc vraiment
ça c'est extrêmement important c'est la
première action c'est la sobriété mais
pour que son entreprise prospère
sereinement Frédéric doit aller au-delà
anticiper à long terme les pénuries et
coûts de l'énergie
en chaque crise une opportunité en
particulier sur l'autonomie énergétique
on va déployer des technologies de
transformation dans le monde du gaz mais
également excité en installant des
panneaux photovoltaïques en utilisant de
la géothermie en utilisant déjà
aujourd'hui 100% d'électricité d'énergie
décarbonée est verte et là aujourd'hui
on va accélérer aussi la l'alternative
de d'usage de gain naturel par du gaz de
synthèse et de la biomasse en grande
masse c'est le cas de le dire
changer d'énergie être autonome Frédéric
se lance dans une transformation
onéreuse qui pour lui serait la clé pour
pérenniser son activité
mais aujourd'hui toutes les entreprises
ne peuvent pas se le permettre
cet environ 150 000 entreprises qui
seraient concernées par l'augmentation
du coût de l'énergie aujourd'hui et à
partir du 1er janvier 2023 autant vous
dire que nous sommes face
potentiellement à risque systémique si
l'entreprise est obligée de baisser le
rideau de réduire la voilure à cause du
coût d'énergie bien évidemment il y a un
impact sur les salariés quand vous
arrêtez votre activité et bien si les
licenciement lorsque vous réduisez la
voilure et bien c'est peut-être des
heures supplémentaires qui ne se font
plus ou tout simplement des intérimaires
que on ne recrute plus et en tout cas un
gel entre guillemets des embauches donc
oui il y aura un impact alors pour
éviter le pire conserver des emplois
tout en réduisant les charges qui pèsent
sur les entreprises les dirigeants
revoient leur mode de fonctionnement
certaines ont pris des positions
effectivement assez radicales changer
complètement l'organisation du travail
travailler la nuit voilà en heure creuse
par rapport au jour mettre en place de
la production électrique à partir de
générateur qui fonctionne
malheureusement avec avec du gasoil des
solutions peu pérennes mais l'état vient
d'annoncer une aide d'urgence aux
entreprises pour en bénéficier plus
besoin de multiplier les demandes auprès
des différents organismes les démarches
sont simplifiées à travers un guichet
unique les entreprises qui ont vu leur
facture d'électricité ou de gaz augmenté
de plus de 50% par rapport à 2021
pourront compter sur un coup de pouce de
l'État mais pour François Asselin ce
geste reste insuffisant lorsque vous
avez une facture qui passe de 80000
euros à un million d'euros combien même
on vous en rabote 28% vous allez payer
720 000 euros ça sera pas suffisant pour
pouvoir continuer à produire nous ce que
nous demandons ce qu'il y ait un guichet
qui soit créé en dernier recours voilà
avant qu'une entreprise baisse le rideau
franchement elles ne sont pour rien
responsables de cette crise que nous
subissons l'énergie et bien faire en
sorte que et bien on regarde une façon
rapide efficace quels sont les moyens
qu'on peut appliquer manière vraiment
discrétionnaire très direct individuel à
cette entreprise qui ne peut pas s'en
sortir à cause du coût de l'énergie
[Musique]
certaines entreprises ont d'ores et déjà
déclaré qu'elle n'hésiteraient pas à
quitter la France pour réimplanter leur
industrie à l'étranger là ou le coût de
l'énergie est plus faible
[Musique]